hello and welcome to co playing Dorrit
yeah that's a team effort team edward so
let's see what we get I just yank it out
see what is coming up with oh yeah I get
some kind of English opening bit offbeat
takes Knight a5 so ed center it's d
following check yeah witness this
shouldn't be very terrifying equal not
equal issue
they can take on c3 now okay Chad to do
that it's at least getting some
imbalance in this pollution
it's got some dynamic he's got the
bishop am now maybe something on the
darks quiz but in return the pawn
structure is a wreck usually the
thinking is that positions like vanna
should should be kind of equal ish but
in an interesting way I am mm-hmm it's
definitely interesting
interesting yeah I don't well okay i can
go Bishop d7 maybe because queen bee 7s
Quincy three okay let's do this first
I mean probably has some kind of c-5
available
maybe this one interesting
okay but okay this is the position you
want it should take on c3 it's kind of
imbalance not be five years interesting
I go rook c8 done
interesting
94 2692 my rook is hanging at the end
ok
yes sitting with the night night pawn
takes Knight a5 is good for me yeah it's
got 93 may be interesting still yeah I
thought night Texian and then I'm not
just seven as a threat rook c8 9787
Bishop e7 whoopsie form I'm not sure
about all this and I didn't see that
okay this is interesting it really is
because he's got this night be three
move available but I have nights you for
can also just take it in but okay I go
on I'd see phone
for potentially Bishop g7 okay
a bit not chief format can still do
matter where are you going with this
piece Bishop g7 is not a move here so
oops why is that possible
we are not saying that it doesn't work
at all but it is very strange case um
yeah that looks bad for white okay
that's two ponds and the batter minor
piece
you
just blocking any a for stuff I look
before you might have not a big deal
though even a five is good I can also
just take us all
a point is very strong against the might
it should be far too quick this pawn yes
yup d 7 or 95 but the point is promoting
it stood still promoting
white resigns Jim I think it was quite
good I am quite a que lo que position
for white but check check I think you
misjudge the CERN Bishop age six move so
here I cannot take here because of check
the hanging pawn with check so castles
looks totally normal and now I went here
yeah this is no interesting this move
yeah it's not something I expected but
it's very interesting I mean he's got
alternatives but let's let's check what
you played ok I took it ok the engine
wants to check on you form yeah I felt
this is more interesting I he's got
various strong bishops there Bishop g5
is what the engine wants to play how
interesting that up early what is the
big point of this move I mean even if I
just play something normal him this is
what the entrance to do but I don't see
how wide is better here I mean these are
targets and then I understand this is a
stronger a strong piece but can always
block it okay the engine goes down to
equal now yeah this is this a sudden no
I mean this feels wrong I mean now he
has to go all the way back his assistant
doesn't seem to work or here Bishop e7
is the only thing maybe after this fight
is losing I think
this is something maybe it's very
unclear engine says equal or anything
can happen yeah here it's pretty much
pretty much over but should be seven is
a bit more interesting black is also bad
I interest 92 are taking it was a pretty
clear advantage for black guarantee are
basically just winning I don't think
there anything special going going on at
the end I can just push push this yeah
not much to do and I asked to avoid this
Bishop 86 move after that it's pretty
much unplayable okay well thanks for
watching